ciao a tutti
e oggi andremo a fare una nuova
challenge prova non rimanere
impressionato gialle bellissimo
attenzione attenzione perché questo
challenge sarà più difficile del solito
perché le cose che vedremo sono e cosa
no
molto particolare ci sono due tipi di
persone i tipi di persone a cui questi
video fanno impressione appunto proprio
a non rimanere impressionato i tipi di
persone a cui questi video piacciono
tantissimo e rimangono super soddisfatti
quindi non appena avrete finito di
vedere questo video commentate che tipo
di persona siete quella che rimane
impressionata o quel che rimane
soddisfatta e vedremo anche noi che tipo
di persona siamo lasciati un bel live se
volete vedere altre sale di sud celere e
prendete i pop corn video tutto schermo
mettetevi comodi e iniziamo subito
allora iniziamo per il primo video
influenti che a strati di pelle dai
piedi e non spa spellando ma non so
perché è bello vedere che la toglie
tutta allora vitale abbiamo già capito
se uno che si impressiona troppo
facilmente da chi sta ripulendo è strano
che perde così tanta pelle dai piedi
forse ho usato una di quelle famose
maschere che fa spellare i piedi tipo
serpente ruth non c'è audio in questo
video il che è ancora più inquietante ma
dai non è male bello vedere che i piedi
sotto sono super morbidi rotto dai devi
guardare la challenge di riguardare lo
so non è mostrato il prossimo modo da
deve guardare tutto oxa come ho fatto
per vederle fine riuscirà a toglierla
dalle dita dei piedi che strano guarda
senti il rumore come si tratta niente
vittoria imparando anche dagli occhi
dall'inizio della crisi è chiuso checa
non è buona per darvi non stai barando
dobbiamo fare stazione guardando tutto è
comunque succede quando vai al mare ti
bruci quando vai al bar e tv si può
capitare che la pelle stella è successo
mi è mai successo nelle spalle tipo
nella schiena
devo fare di te vol e barare oggi
prendiamo se alla fine questo video
vitale si sentirà male o immaginati
immaginati che col è presente non so se
fosse volte lo stesso gioco voi da
piccoli di mettere la colla nelle mani
puoi aspettare che si asciuga e tirarla
si sa è il massimo che cosa certo dai
sembrano guarda dei piedi nuovi adesso
non so perché sopra sono scuri porta
questo pre sono un po neri dying
guardano per piegare la cia ha affatto
perché un rumore è divertente quanto
dura ancora rumore ma quello che non fa
male bella morta
certo il successo anche a me spellare
successo tutti oddio che saranno nome
the agito sotto la barra a pat guarda ai
suoi figli del vetro non potete scriver
la pelle
oddio è tutta la pelle che ha tolto
liber terra la vetta schifo ragazzi mano
assente dai sara varone giusti guardarlo
se si toglie tacco a secco ok ora
riuscita a farla finita così perfino il
piede devi guardare no no magari ok
vediamo molto ha usato una maschera
sottotipi di maschere afoso di te per i
piedi che in pratica a farti tornare la
pelle supermorbida dpa destino fanno
questo feeling ma e natura fossi stati
là perché fuori già in acqua
ho guardato dentro quindi se non penso
che pur se il nostro davvero ma che stai
bene proviamo anche noi questa maschera
vediamo subito di non prevedere i piedi
ha detto che costava solo un dollaro
questa maschera
ora i piedi alla lingua non a lino
praticamente la pelle smartphones
morbida come quella di un bambino guarda
che ti metti dai 57 gioia così è tutta
l'appello ma solo un pezzo abbiamo anche
l'altro perché è infatti doveva
aspettare un po di più
strano perché cambia colore
cioè la pelle che sta togliendo e scura
invece quella sotto e più bianca e più
chiamano non so se sia per il consolato
dello ied e poi tornare nuovo senso di
profumazioni perché in tanti vendono
questa maschera questo caso si promuove
strada cioè massimo tra tema
ok prossimo video
poi dalla mano questo non si fa
impressione ma questo di colla massa
sembra così realistico
questo è come se dei glitter sopra dice
così bene
è questo che non fa impressione no
questo ok perché comunque percolla non è
un appello per la mamma
però è bello da vedere secondo termini
ma è una figata come il fantasista che
il tassista il milan dovrebbe aveva
valori dovrebbe atterrarlo in tabella è
bello vedere come se tira tutt'altra poi
preferite quelli di pelle vero quelli di
colla venola serata e questi sono presi
per son belli e mettersi poi sempre
perché si di questa cosa che le strappa
lo so e fanno le mani più morbido anche
questo da un pezzo ma siamo parla non
penso il fatto di avere i piedi più
morbide perché togli la pelle ruvida è
questa a disegnarsi dei falli rossi come
se si stesse riferendo tipo del morbo
del morbillo l vari oppure brufoli non
lo so non fa più impressione così magari
non baglieri dovendolo già così dice che
lei non penso che vengano stampi di
colore delle mani il pil non so perché
vuole non si voglia di provarlo anche a
me fatemi sapere se volete che lo provi
agria cosa mi fa molta impressione
sembra per le vera io quello che facevo
dap il colera metterle tra le dita tipo
e poi lo speravo dal dito
lo facevi allora prossimo video
oddio colonia punto nero in pratica in
maschera contro i punti neri visto da
vicino ma sembra uno slide che sembra
gelatina perché così mezzo trasparente
oddio ma stavolta lungo in pratica sta
togliendo i punti neri dalla pelle
cioè è bellissimo vedere che li toglie
non lo so da un senso di liberazione
dalle stranezze però allo stesso tempo
fa un pò schifo
wow
non mi immaginavo che fossero grandi
bottini sono quelli piccolini vede quali
siamo anche i denti neri per sempre
stato così sereni forse sì forse
bertolaso ha riba che fa gigantissimo
nostri con oggi a scoppio tipo che si
stanno non si vedrebbe così vicino
eppure quando ti riguarda tipo i punti
neri quando ad evitare fano minuscoli
qua c'è troppo tipo grasso a novo che
cosa stanno tutti questi i peli del 66 o
mio dio sono scioccata perché camillo
posto venendo voglia di fare un pilot
fism altri tutta la mia faccia e
togliere tutte queste fammi coltivano
tipo per averli offesi grossi ma penso
che tutti noi in realtà ce l'abbiamo
giustizia che non li abbiamo mai visti
al microscopio
ok aiuto oddio questa bianca si vede
meno forse
[Musica]
ma sono tipo di dei pezzi di stoffa ecco
perché ci sono della maschera no non
avrei mai pensato di punti nesi si
sarebbero stati così schifosi vedere da
vicino sembrano brufoli giganti siete
punti neri nei pori della pelle con la
schifezza ii e cosa si che tu riesci a
guardando questo quindi ci siamo
invertiti adesso oddio loro prossimo
video qua stanno provando la sera
facciale quindi la sera quella calda che
metti sull'appello interiore sulle gambe
si usa per togliere i peli poi fai un
penny proprio mostrato così e tutti peli
non so perché l'ho messa non lo so forse
aveva pantaloni neri marzo vediamo
ma tu che mi sbrigo tutto per un movente
non hai capito più indietro del dolore
oddio c'è meno male e rapido
se non è qualcosa ti fa male per tanto
tempo però sembra terribile
nell'orecchio magari che dentro il baso
zio ma poi sarà un male cane del mare
tra il meno dura poco il dolore penso
facendo leva io no a questo farà male
male male male male andiamo farei mai
ora dovete tenere l'altro non se lo farà
togliere o meno male non fanno vedere
dopo tutti sulla barba sulle guance tra
le ho provato a questa sera a caldo fa
malissimo sulle guance deve essere
terribile dolore pure il naso mi fa
impressione che infila bacchette 30
sto dicendo non verrà più agli
appuntamenti nel naso allora dopo rimane
riuscissimo però è che il colore
ecco vitale tornato in modalità non
guardo più niente
ma ha fatto vedere tutti belli una
ragazza vediamo secondo è anche un
pericoloso a questa cosa dimettersi
leonardo può farti male a qualche pena
no sì che secondo me loro performata
oddio mi dispiace un sacco per lei non
sapevo che se facessero queste cose per
togliere i veli nel naso e meglio se lo
fa qualcun altro perché da solo non si
riesce
non mi sono stremato predominio l'ansia
non c'è riuscita o no oddio si è
staccato un pezzo di narice no non solo
faccia
mi sembra indumenti ten diventare non
sono mai e poi mai
[Musica]
e terribile quando tirano poi senza
tirare in commissione se infatti che ad
esempio peggio si fa ancora più male
[Musica]
oddio queste due assi dai brand aiuto
con fini allora ragazzi che si erano i
video fateci sapere se vi hanno
impressionato o se siete rimasti
soddisfatti per me il peeling della
pelle
e della colla mi ha soddisfatto mi
piacevano vedere poi noi se quella sia i
punti neri vi faceva un sacco schifo e
anche questo della serate invece faceva
schifo tutto tutto stasera tra dei punti
neri o consiglieri erano quasi
soddisfacente invece è bello vedere come
venivano via invece questa punta di
ferro vedere come gli tolgono i punti
neri si è bello e non è bello vedere i
punti neri da vicino fateci sapere se vi
siete impressionati o se siete
soddisfatti quale vi ha fatto più schifo
quale vi ha soddisfatto di più lasciati
cipolle di timestamp nei commenti
consigliateci che altre challenge che
altri video reazione commentario fare
nei commenti
e ora vi lasciamo con quattro cardini su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video challenge video divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite
ciao